the jurogan experience my lucid dreaming
has become
so where i i
you know that feeling where in a dream
where you're in a high precipice
and you think you're gonna fall now in a
dream i can jump off of it i know oh i'm
in a dream
i can [ __ ] i'll be jumping i'm going
to float or fly or sink slowly and
safely to the ground
i get the same feeling in real life on a
high i we were crossing the mississippi
once
and i was behind the wheel and i started
to have this panic attack
and [ __ ] chaley's editing in the
passenger seat
and i'm like take the wheel take the
wheel i've
i'm freaking out a bit so now like i
i need to be a [ __ ] regular dosage of
xanax well
hold on before you get into that let me
take you back to the lucid dreaming
thing like when did that start
over the years i [ __ ] recently well
no five years how many years it's it's
getting better all the time
you're better at lucid dreaming than you
were before did was it uh
i had to come out this morning i took a
seroquel which i try not to what's that
it's a very powerful anti-psychotic
that uh oh it's probably bad for your
liver
i'm taking it antipsychotic because it i
[ __ ] sleep
i can sleep like 14 hours i'll get up to
piss
go like lucidly out of the dream
remembering the dream
and go back hang on i have to piss just
like i pissed here on the podcast
i can get up out of a dream say please
hold dream
piss lucidly i'm not in a closet like
sean rouse
so sarah can go back for you yeah
and that's why i use it very sparingly
jesus christ that sounds amazing
it's [ __ ] the best like what else
does it do though
is you cannot share dreams with people i
know it's a hack premise
but where i woke up this morning i went
to bed after [ __ ] red band finally
called me
and told me oh yeah i prompted joe rogan
to finally respond to you
what time am i going to be i didn't know
what time i'm supposed to be here
he told me the address i think you were
touching the wrong number
no i'm pretty sure [ __ ] no no myth me
do you mean uh do you wanna uh if you
wanna put a half a million dollar bet
i'll use your half million as a down
payment on that [ __ ]
comedian grove this comedian group um
i'll show you the texts but we were just
saying something though
yeah about lucid dreaming lucid dreams
so
so but i was in such a state when i woke
up this morning
from dreams where you know the dream
where you wake up and go
oh [ __ ] thank god everything was
going right but i wanted this is what i
want to know did
the lucid dreams start independently of
this cereal stuff
oh they started yeah since i was a kid
oh you've always had lucid dreams
i remember when i was probably an early
teenager the first time that i could
correlate
that stomach drop feeling of when you're
about to fall off of something but you
could fly
yeah do you have flying dreams sometimes
yeah
but those have grown where
okay now i can fly now i know i'm in a
dream i can kind of control it
i i know what's going on and i can wake
up
and piss and go back to bed and get
right back into the same dream did you
read books about this
is this something that you just figured
out as you were doing it as you're
having these lucid dreams
yeah but at the same problem that
everyone who has dreams he can't quite
remember it but
the feeling the stomach drop feeling the
oh i'm i'm floating
things that connect your brain back to
okay i know i'm in a dream but i'm not
gonna wake up let's [ __ ] with this
but you so you but you got better over
the years just by having lucid dreams
over and over again and realizing
what's what's the thing that you do that
gets you out of the dream
don't do that and just figured out what
to do to stay in that
sometimes you you wake up or sometimes
you're only alerted to the fact that
you're dreaming because you hit
bat bat bat oh i get a text message okay
reality's on the outside it's [ __ ] me
up
shut off your phone before you go to bed
but the serial quilt
is more extreme it's bigger it makes you
sleep longer
i don't know i don't know the science
behind it but but is is a circle
making you have more lucid dreams or
better control of your lucid dreams
it's it's making me sleep longer and
uh making me more aware
that i'm in a dream i don't know i just
because i know
circle dreams i [ __ ] lived an entire
these altered states where i woke up and
i'm like
is there still a receipt in my pocket
from that dream that i can
prove there's two different worlds it
was that [ __ ] up but you can't explain
that to people
i wanted to call anyone i woke up
it was just a dream there's a movie
about uh recording dreams that was
pretty [ __ ] good
that i saw the other night i think it's
called come true
and it's about apparently there is some
technology
that they're working on right now where
they can record
certain aspects of your thoughts like if
you're thinking about a triangle
it'll show an image of a triangle and
they think read something about it yeah
they think they're going to get to the
point
where they're going to be able to get at
least some sort of a reasonable
facsimile of the visuals that you're
having in your dreams
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience